ahora comparemos estos dos alternos y
estas dos moléculas aunque se parecen
muchísimo resulta que no son la misma
molécula ok estos al que nos tienen un
doble enlace por aquí que hace que estas
moléculas no puedan rotar a lo largo de
este enlace para verse idénticas la una
a la otra y entonces no son la misma
molécula pero como se parecen tanto y lo
único que necesitarían para ser
igualitas sería rotar a lo largo de este
eje son estéreo isómeros pero bueno
vamos a ponerle nombre a estas dos
moléculas y para eso tenemos que empezar
por numerada los carbonos este es el
carbono uno el dos el tres y el cuatro
como tenemos cuatro carbonos lo que
tenemos es un bote no butano
y el enlace doble empieza en el segundo
carbono así es que es un 2 bueno de este
lado tenemos aquí que esto es el carbono
1 2
4 así es que también tenemos un bote no
guste no
y el enlace de doble también empieza en
el segundo carbono entonces tenemos
también un dos butano pero pues estas
dos moléculas no son iguales justo
porque no podemos rotar a lo largo de
este enlace y entonces no está muy bien
que les estemos dando exactamente el
mismo nombre por lo que existe un
sistema para ponerles nombres que
distingan a estos estéreo isómeros bueno
en realidad hay dos sistemas uno es el
sistema systems y otro es el sistema ez
y vamos a empezar por el sistema systems
porque es el más antiguo es el original
aunque el sistema ez es el más eficiente
bueno y cuando estamos usando el sistema
sistemas de nomenclatura lo que hacemos
es buscar dos grupos funcionales
idénticos en estas moléculas pues
tenemos el grupo funcional metilo
lo que hacemos es extender la línea que
dibuja el enlace doble y fijarnos en si
los grupos funcionales quedaron del
mismo lado de la línea o quedaron
parados por la línea si quedaron del
mismo lado de la línea decimos que
tenemos un cis y luego el nombre que
teníamos de la molécula 62 buteno y si
extendemos la línea del doble enlace y
los grupos funcionales quedaron
separados por la línea entonces decimos
que tenemos un trans gay 6 y trans
vienen del latin trans es a través de o
más allá de por ejemplo cuando tomas un
vuelo transatlántico estás tomando un
vuelo a través del océano atlántico
bueno pero cuál de estos dos isómeros es
más estable pues tenemos que pensar en
el impedimento estético que es un efecto
que podemos observar cuando tenemos una
reacción que generalmente ocurriría sin
ningún problema pero que como en la
molécula en particular tenemos grupos
funcionales muy voluminosos entonces la
reacción no sucede y estos grupos metilo
son muy voluminosos y se estorban
mutuamente
11 es por el impedimento estético entre
más alejados estén estos dos grupos
funcionales más estable va a ser la
molécula ok y aquí en este y somero los
grupos metilo están muy cerca por estar
del mismo lado del enlace doble y se
están estorbando así es que este y
somero el trans todos vote no es más
estable es más estable
bueno veamos otro ejemplo a ver tenemos
por aquí
un enlace doble y después
esto por acá a ver queremos ponerle el
nombre a esta molécula y para ponerle el
nombre de acuerdo al sistema cis trans
lo que tenemos que hacer es buscar dos
grupos funcionales uno enlazado a cada
uno de los carbonos de este doble enlace
pero que sean idénticos ok sin embargo
aquí pues tenemos un grupo metilo y un
grupo propio y esos no son iguales así
es que no los podemos usar para
determinar si utilizamos cis o trans sin
embargo aquí hay un pequeño truco si
podemos utilizar los hidrógenos aunque
este carbono está enlazado con un
hidrógeno y este otro carbono también
está enlazado con un hidrógeno entonces
estos dos si son iguales y además
están del otro lado del doble enlace por
lo que esta molécula va a ser un isómero
estético trans pero bueno no siempre
sucede que tenemos allí a los hidrógenos
para salvar el caso hay veces en las que
la notación systems no se puede utilizar
porque no tenemos grupos idénticos de
los dos lados del carbono y entonces lo
que hacemos es utilizar la anotación ez
entonces ponemos otra molécula con doble
enlace
para utilizar la anotación y z ok
el sistema ez se basa en darle prioridad
a los grupos funcionales de acuerdo al
número atómico de los átomos más
cercanos al doble enlace gay entonces lo
que vamos a hacer empezando con este
carbono es fijarnos en los átomos que
están directamente enlazados con el
carbono en este caso es el bromo y el
carbono ahora el bromo tiene un número
atómico 35 mientras el carbono tiene un
número atómico 6
entonces el bromo tiene una mayor
prioridad que el carbono así es que este
grupo funcional tiene la mayor prioridad
y este otro grupo funcional tiene la
menor prioridad y vamos a hacer lo mismo
con este otro carbono los átomos
directamente enlazados con el carbono
son el hidrógeno y el oxígeno y el
oxígeno tiene un mayor número atómico
por lo que este grupo funcional tiene
una mayor prioridad
este otro y entonces hacemos el mismo
truco de antes que es extender la línea
del doble enlace para ver de qué lado
están los grupos funcionales de mayor
prioridad
como podemos ver en este exterior y
somero los grupos funcionales de mayor
prioridad están del otro lado de la
línea y entonces este va a ser un
estéreo y somero y gay porque escogimos
la letra e pues esta viene de la palabra
en alemán enrique enrique que significa
en oposición ok porque estos dos grupos
funcionales están en lados opuestos del
doble enlace bueno ahora veamos el otro
estéreo y somero así es que vamos a
rotar este carbono para obtener otra
molécula porque en realidad como es un
enlace doble no lo podemos rotar y
entonces la otra molécula que obtenemos
es un
este lado se queda igualito
h3 y de este lado el bromo queda por
abajo y el grupo metilo queda por acá
y repito no se puede llegar de esta
molécula a esta molécula porque el doble
enlace no permite rotaciones entonces
son números estéticos distintos pero
bueno asignamos las prioridades el bromo
tiene un mayor número atómico que el
carbono entonces le damos prioridad al
bromo y del lado de este otro carbono
el oxígeno tiene un mayor número atómico
que el hidrógeno entonces éste sustituye
ente tiene mayor prioridad que este
hidrógeno extendemos la línea del doble
enlace y notamos que los grupos con
mayor prioridad se encuentran del mismo
lado de la línea y entonces este es el
exterior y somero
z ok donde la seta viene de sus m
la palabra alemana que significa juntos
bueno veamos otro ejemplo utilizando la
anotación zeta este va a estar un
poquito más complicado entonces tenemos
nuestro doble enlace de este lado
tenemos un promo y un cloro y de este
lado vamos a tener un al de ido y un
alcohol ok y entonces para determinar si
este es un exterior y somero
o un no acepta tenemos que asignar las
prioridades nos fijamos en este carbono
tenemos por aquí el bromo y el cloro
buscamos en la tabla si no nos acordamos
cuáles son los números atómicos y
resulta que el bromo tiene un mayor
número atómico entonces tiene mayor
prioridad y el cloro pues tiene menor
prioridad pero bueno eso fue de este
carbono luego nos pasamos a este otro
carbono y tenemos que determinar cuál de
estos dos sustituye entes tiene mayor
prioridad entonces empezamos por estos
dos carbonos que están enlazados
directamente con este carbono pero
resulta que los dos tienen el mismo
número atómico por ser los dos carbonos
entonces tenemos que ir más allá y
fijarnos en qué átomos están enlazados
con cada uno de estos
carbonos y lo más fácil es desarrollar
toda la molécula entonces tenemos por
aquí este carbono del doble enlace que
está enlazado con estos dos carbonos
y bueno este carbono tiene un doble
enlace con el oxígeno por lo que vamos a
pensar que está enlazado con 2 oxígenos
aunque ya hemos hecho este truco antes y
también tiene un hidrógeno y de este
lado este carbono está enlazado con dos
hidrógenos un hidrógeno otro hidrógeno y
luego con un oxígeno con un oxígeno este
oxígeno está enlazado con otro hidrógeno
pero no lo vamos a necesitar entonces
este carbono está enlazado con un
oxígeno oxígeno y luego hidrógeno
oxígeno oxígeno y luego hidrógeno y este
otro carbono está enlazado con un
oxígeno y otros dos hidrógenos como los
números atómicos de estos dos carbono
son iguales nos empezamos a fijar en los
números atómicos de las moléculas a las
que están enlazados y comparamos uno por
uno tenemos aquí un oxígeno que tiene
un número atómico que cualquier otro
oxígeno así es que continuamos tenemos
otro oxígeno y este sí tiene un mayor
número atómico que cualquier otro
hidrógeno así es que este sustituye ente
tiene mayor prioridad que este otro a
este le ponemos el número uno ya éste le
ponemos el número dos y hacemos el mismo
truco de extender la línea del enlace
doble y podemos notar que los sustituye
entes con mayor prioridad se encuentran
del mismo lado de la línea entonces este
es un estéreo y somero z
el sistema ez funciona para cualquier
doble enlace a diferencia del sistema si
es trans que necesita que dos de sus
sustituye entes sean idénticos por lo
que muchísimas personas prefieren
utilizar únicamente del sistema ez sin
embargo por razones históricas en
muchísimos libros de química orgánica
sigue apareciendo el sistema
si es trans cuando es posible utilizarlo